es geht mir heute um die cdu heute war
ein wichtiger tag denn die cdu hat den
fahrplan festgelegt um einen neuen
parteichef zu wählen das erste mal
dürfen die mitglieder und
mitgliederinnen entscheiden rund 400.000
sind es und seit wochen ja seit monaten
wird eigentlich darum gerungen wer der
fünf männer die sich bisher mehr oder
weniger direkt zur wahl gestellt haben
wer soll es denn machen fünf männer fünf
männer aus nrw fünf männer und sie haben
richtig gehört keine frau ja wo sind
denn eigentlich die frauen wo sind denn
eigentlich die frauen in der cdu die ja
immer wieder gesagt haben diese partei
die wir so männerdominiert warum steht
denn jetzt eigentlich keine frau auch
warum sitzt ihr sind die frauen
abgetaucht sind sie möglicherweise zu
feige sind sie möglicherweise nicht
qualifiziert genug jetzt wäre die zeit
aufzustehen und zu sagen ich bin eine
frau und ich möchte auch cdu-chef werden
und solange das nicht passiert muss ich
sagen schluss mit dem gejammer liebe
frauen in der cdu ihr habt es sonst
selbst versammelt
also jan mit feigheit hat das natürlich
gar nichts zu tun jede frau die jetzt
antritt weiß dass sie für immer mit
angela merkel verglichen wird ja und
frauen sind klug die ziehen nicht in
schlachten die sie auf jeden fall
verlieren die übermächtige angela merkel
drückt alles was jetzt erst noch kommen
könnte ja ich gehe ja auch als
männlicher sänger nicht nach justin
timberlake auf die bühne zum beispiel ja
da weiß ich ja auf jeden fall dass ich
verlieren werde oder ich bin größenwahn
sich und das sind frauen zu glück
meistens nicht aber ihr geht es ja um
die führung einer partei geht es um die
führung einer partei die jetzt 16 jahre
lang die kanzlerin auch gestellt hat und
wir haben es bei der wahl zum
cdu-vorsitzenden jahr im januar dieses
jahres schon erlebt da waren drei männer
die standen norbert röttgen friedrich
merz und armin laschet keine frau auf
dem boden und was ist aus ihnen geworden
ich habe die frage ist ja wenn wir wenn
es der partei so schlecht geht und es
angeblich auch so viele frauen gibt die
sich immer wieder nicht richtig estate
fühlen in der union in der cdu dann ist
auch die große frage wo sind sie denn
jetzt warum tritt denn eigentlich
niemand an warum steht niemand auf die
cdu ist eine partei hat eine lange
geschichte und es hat auch mit
strukturen zu tun das sind nicht einfach
nur 16 jahre angela merkel sondern
dahinter steckt eine männerdominierte
struktur die viele jahre existiert die
nicht mal einfach so weg aber jetzt sage
ich ihnen was und erwähnt sie sind ja
glaube ich cdu mit so ist das seit
vielen jahren er ist ja nicht so dass in
der partei nicht versucht wird frauen zu
fördern wenn man sich das geeiere um den
parteivorsitz jetzt anschaut dann wäre
das ein leichtes doch für eine frau zu
sagen ich breche diesem elend auf die es
da gibt aber nur warten sie's doch mal
ab wir haben jetzt anfang november die
wissenschafter ist ende januar wäre
jetzt zu früh auf den sockel springt ist
auch ganz schnell wieder unten dh da
sind auch noch viele die jetzt jede
menge zeit haben sich ordentlich zu
verbrennen in den kommenden wochen und
monaten werde daher zum schluss übrig
bleibt kann durchaus auch eine frau sein
also lange wird das verfahren nicht
dauern also sie müssen ihr ende januar
doch jetzt kommt der mitglieder
entscheiden da wird aber erstmal gucken
aber wählen tut der parteitag ende
januar und wenn es mal gucken was
passiert haben sie denn einen favoriten
bei den frauen bei den frauen gibt es
viele favoritinnen die ich hätte aber
die sage ich ihnen nicht aber es gibt
viele kluge sehr gute frauen übrigens
jüngere als auch erfahrene politikerin
in vielen funktionen in den ländern in
den kreisverbänden und auch auf der
bundesebene herzlich wir haben ja diese
tolle bz kolumne auch gehabt mein
gerechter zorn war mein gerechnet oder
war mein zorn über die cdu-frauen denn
jetzt eigentlich gerecht naja ich weiß
ich weiß nicht ist es denn so wichtig ob
eine frau oder ein mann die cdu führt
eigentlich geht es doch um die
qualifikation also die frage ob sich
jetzt eine frau findet oder nicht ist
suggestiv also sie haben gesagt es würde
sich keiner finden weil sich keiner
traut woher wissen wir aber
ich halte die idee halte diese waren in
der cdu nicht mehr so schüchtern
nicht trauen und sagen ich will
vorsitzende werden also das kann ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen also wieso haben
sie ja das gibt es gar keine frau
derzeit überhaupt die kompetenz hätte
nein das ist überhaupt nicht also das
sagen haben wir eine rinne nicht weil
sie zu sehen sodass ich war schon wieder
unterschiedlich
aber da ich habe ihn aber dass die
frauen erst mal abwarten das ist ein
langstrecken hören muss man nicht jetzt
schon seine ganze immer noch mal oder
schob ihn ja ja sagt die frauen sind
nicht zu feige nein aber es
sind sicherlich nicht zufolge das würde
ich wieder allgemeinen doch noch für die
cdu geltend machen aber sie haben das
einfach unterstellt dass die sich
deswegen nicht melden weil sie mich
gefragt haben natürlich kenne ich jede
menge frauen in der union die das
charisma haben parteivorsitzende zu sein
ich nehme sie auch nicht so wie rainer
wendt weil sie sich ja selbst nicht
gemeldet haben deswegen wollen wir jetzt
noch nicht nennen aber das wäre ganz
modern jetzt können sie über personen
nicht mehr erregen sich selbst gemeldet
war wieso wenn sie sich sie werden ihre
gründe haben wir eigentlich genau
verfolgen das faszinierende und da sehen
denn liegt genau daran wie gesagt kein
name dass sie selbst sich nicht sicher
sind das ist keine frauen jedoch gar
nicht sie doch natürlich alle also ja
soll ich noch mal sagen sondern kristina
schröder aus hessen
christina dolls julia doppel hinaus
fragen hier tolle frauen die das alle
können mit meinem arzt wenn ich auf der
bank sie von angeraten ich sie fragen ja
auch nicht warum kommen alle die sich
für den parteivorsitz bewerben aus
nordrhein-westfalen und alle aus
derselben gegend ab 1 das haben sie aber
spüren dass nachricht aber genau das ist
ja das kernproblem ist würde es ja für
eine frau noch viel einfacher mache eine
frau die selbst aus nordrhein westfalen
kommt oder aus einem anderen
bundesländer ist da natürlich noch
einfach zu sagen guck mal ich breche
diese männerphalanx die wiedersehen auf
und geh rein weil ich der meinung bin
habe ich aber richtige schon sehr
abkühle aus nordrhein-westfalen zum
beispiel jetzt in den bundestag gekommen
ist die chance für integration aber
jetzt ist er rennt allerdings ein
problem sein dass dieses männer netzwerk
doch sehr dominant ist dass man angst
hat oder scheut seine ganze energie
dagegen auf zu werden wenn ich mir
vorstellen müsste ich musste jeden tag
gegen friedrich merz ankämpfen das wäre
mir ehrlich gesagt auch
mit der cdu für nicht so solidarisch für
sie sich das
vorstellt einmal dran ja sie haben dort
über netzwerke gesprochen netzwerk
glaube ich sind sehr wichtig 23 prozent
der aktuellen abgeordneten der cdu sind
frauen das ist jede vierte person also
reicht es offensichtlich nicht dass man
jetzt eine frau hat die chefin werden
kann sondern man muss auch weiter diese
strukturen anschauen wie viele frauen
müssen erstmal diese plätze bekommen
damit man ein netzwerk das ist genau
frauen hinter das trikot war das thema
wie kann das denn sein nach nach gefühlt
100 jahren angela merkel dass in der cdu
die männer netzwerke dominieren das ist
doch ein märchen also die wahl wird
reden moerser liberalen abgeordneten
weil die frau war ja immer besetzt durch
angela merkel musste man sich ja keine
sorgen ich auch ihre frauen also in den
kreisverbänden der weihnachtsmarkt ist
schaut man was heißt die kreisverbände
der cdu wenn man sich da die
führungskräfte mal anschaut wie viele
wie viele männer darauf den
führungspositionen nicht frei machen für
irgendeine jüngere hat aber jetzt haben
wir doch darüber geredet ganz nach oben
zu kommen sie können alle nördlichen
kreis landesverbände überspringen und
könnten sagen ich traue mir zu chefin
der gesamten partei zu werden das ist ja
das was wir gerade sehen die männer
netzwerke gerade in der union die
funktionieren ja zurzeit gar nicht so
richtig denn sie müssen sie müssen ihr
netzwerk nehmen und es mit einem anderen
zusammenhang also ein netzwerk alleine
hat derzeit nicht genug aber
zurückhaltend und männern netzwerke sie
hat organisation zum netzwerke so ist
die partie nun einmal aufgebraucht da
geht es um die
cdu-mittelstandsvereinigung die
landesverbände das sind die netzwerke
aber nicht männer und frauen ja
sonderlich lange geraden auch ein
respekt vor dem amt ist und vielleicht
auch ein hauch angst weil man hat
gesehen was mit laschet passiert ist mit
dieser vernichtung und noch eine gewagte
these vielleicht fürchten manche auch
eine komplette durchleuchtung der
lebenslage wenn das resident voll im amt
ist und auch gewisse angst dann ist auch
das gejammer über den punkt es gibt zu
wenig frauen in der politik nicht mehr
angemessen denn dann muss man ja
konstatieren frauen sind offenbar zu eng
an mustern und dann ist es in ordnung da
muss man einfach sagen dann haben frauen
angst in der politik aber dann jammert
bitte auch nicht und ich mache jetzt mal
das klassische klischee man grau das
mache ich sonst eigentlich gar nicht
aber es muss jetzt mal sein dann muss
dieses mit dem gejammer schlussendlich
den quoten aber gar nicht mehr jammern
sondern die frage wo es funktioniert wir
haben gerade eben haben sie gesagt es
sind nur knapp 24 prozent der frauen
drin da wäre noch viel zu tun da müsste
doch überhaupt erstmal die bahn gehören
ist daran immer wieder auch von den
frauen dass gesagt wird ja wir haben es
hier schwer durchzukommen und manchmal
ist es das sagen die erste einfach
anträge und funktionen gegen bei der
bundestags- vizepräsidentin waren die
frauen sofort auf der matte vor ort wird
beim auf
andere frau grütters die gesagt haben
also da muss auf jeden fall eine frauen-
und die haben sie doch nicht sofort
durchgesetzt bei der ersten gelegenheit
standen die sofort auf der matte und
haben gesagt führungsfunktionen dann
mussten frauen hinterher und warum und
wie ein neues licht auf und sagt jetzt
wich cdu-chefin werden wo wir erst mal
abwarten ob sie wissen mehr her wenn ich
glaube nicht aus dieses wird sind und
ich glaube auch das ist gut so seite 17
cdu auch noch in ihrer alten mentalität
ich glaube dass man manchmal posten hin
und her geschoben wurden und dass es
nicht immer nur um leistung ging und
jetzt geht es um leistung und da muss
man jetzt erstmal wieder hinkommen ich
glaube man muss erst ganz viel
bewältigen bis man sich neu aufstellen
kann und ehrlich gesagt herr benz punkt
vom ganz am anfang die frauen warten ab
wir haben noch zeit nicht gleich am
anfang sein ganzes pulver verschießen
die kommen noch